вся сила в куртках обидва навідаю дітям
потрібні пузо шкіль не мережі вже просто
наскільки мені рідний цьому всякого суті
теж мій другий будинок частот word if no
majo де ти хочеш пак і концерти в
палаті та по Україні по крилатому за
безглуздому
так само як ти pioneer і маже 20 руки в
тому алена віночка співала пісню про
орлят просто виду і записалася у корови
і гурту методу патчу, що купив класі
лося спи волосся у млин але причина ти чекав
archi грала на домбрі танцювала благаю
вала
дпс до будете вбиті нсд винні
реалізую на сцені
давай
вважаю що дуже необхідні моменти для
будь-яку дитину це просто
загальноосвітній важливий стан
артистом і не станете
але як це приємно коли ви можете
просто в колі друзів знати якийсь
інструмент або сісти і до рояля і
зіграти якийсь нехай нік дні не дуже
складну мелодію там якусь популярну
пісеньку яку знають усі тандит на я
наташку частоти зірка you were їздового
ти святий своєю грою на бандурі кожен
займаєте у куртку ж 5 років їх від кіно
мало з надзвичайної хобі на устілці
захопити нині я набираю в ансамблі
золоті струни
warthog допам них ви означає, якщо знати
but new професію
я обожнюю закінчать і заочно верстак по
класу бандура укріплені тут на сайті
багата мої будні в ірак а джигурду
бандуристів
1 600 секцію Карибської палати дітей тієї
у нас два найму найкращим ви хуан сам все
скарб шутери рок і он і малює свій
шедевр художні студії чи плять us to
cook росту з салону го this to do лише
3 і старше мліють адже цирковій студії
бачуна беббіт куполом цирку
чому гурт кузов данж лах
хован зможе testino шпагату палітрі
вигнута в ідеальний місця джек обкладений
дзьоба ти трюма булава ми мене мама
лає я на канікулах сиджу на 40 суді
години чотири-п'ять мене мама народжуючись за
те, що я приходжу пізно і що їм
відповісти мені подобається це що я можу
зробити по палаті пуску, що вона
займається близько 10 тисяч хлопців та
дівчат відволікає як раніше говорили
відволікає дітей від вулиці зараз не так
від вулиці відволікає як від комп'ютерів від
сидіння вдома
а сколіозів та інших викривлень
хребта це розвиває їх фізично
це розвивають їх моральним в Україні
підори 1000 державних паза шкільних
початкових закладів з палац це центри
дітей та й над 280 чесних зусиль
міністерстві почти наук і заповнюють так
та куртки у протилежному доступних 2 роки
стану ще більше їх розвиток
підбашеною новими та соціальними
ініціативами президента України сьогодні
за шкільну святі вухо плану 40
сотки у дітей вид зао ​​мікель кістки
діточки багато віку
хоча в ініціативах міністерства на 2013 рік
14 руки місця 80 але чи треба ставити
сотки поставити сотки треба не можеш
живості дітям реалізувати smm warthog в
суд вночі синонім dosleep здоров'я на
дня в них його не нададуть батьки одягнених
дужчий на червовий занять обжим риють
гравці караоке в пітері ось і будь
найкраще сцени країни втрата коротко шийк
андрей скоро coromant ух перший
національний
мажете фтору мільйона устілки
українській школі риф нині ведмедю та пазу
шкіль не гурт до там де ти малюють
танцюють спиваються рають на музичних
інструментах і на ви ж їсте
астрономію секції 9 палат дітей
таїнство центрах творчо
протизастудні 2 роки в кілі кисть
учню 3 позики або авурт як might be
62 че
звірами мастям і проблем не битиме
адже у міністерства святі наукою я
стрибав від наводить sims куди
кіровоградської області
запишемо кого манула уроку діянь stand з
ним word кивнула най акти зовнішню
головний all середах дитя чогось і творчо
у севастополі
миски палат дітей юного той трохи дня
просіяти лицар куртки фотостудії
заняття ведуть на 3000 хлопці то
дівчат скритної популярніший куртки
хореографічний стиль пін-ап від та пліші
миска влада завершити ремонт літньої
естради шип равлик там туристи можуть і
монстр вати свої найкраще по бочках то
друзям є резерви, які ми будемо
використовувати і звичайно
розширювати кількість гуртків тому що
вони просто затребувані
районний будинок для тебе читаю надку
творчості місці хвороби на Рівненщині
так вже розширюються тут командує кілька
затока їх відкрити паршивого рису
він на головному будинку творчості зможе
займатися 700 школярів для місць та париж
них 6 100 найпопулярніших арештуєте грудки
хореографії музика студія
декоративно-ужиткової майстерності та
декоративного рідкого замість слони
початковий образ
артів больового поки що там теж
дістати багата дітей іди ти така різанина
вікула категорія
на херсонщині взялися віддасте а чого
туризму скаже його розум так заляже вигляд
спеціалізованих горських нині в
області 9 секті зіркових буде туризму
пишу фітни та велосипедну частину
боярський
однак щоб їх злегка дурнувати якщо
дасть правого турпоходу дити
дивний спеціально кута даних
залах на заради їхнього шлюбу та
у Чернігові дня питання у досконалій
Туреччини українських зма ганичівську
молодець автомодельному спорту замкнувшись
боролася 11 куманди різьблених q точці
України
усидить його хуан сидячих бурців бог дано
пропонована ся тут расовим модуль його
не їм уже сир і батьку парадів і
плескати за хоп і весь зачіп годину маленьку
гонщик
ст і стати призером чемпіонату України
усного так їх за нейтронного мага не
трек для полігону
готові ще б ти в нових жителям для
щоб дітей на чат і нас
брати участь добре не вимагав відлітаємо
початкову матеріальну базу
треба купава тенові володіння якшаться
та розумної техніки ми гарячі 5 руки
повстаннях при 73 marimba за картиною
божевілля всередину іванові картини куб його ти
я хочу говорити про іншу натуралістів
мтс по стіні треба купати інвентар
кінцю еманації плани біт поведінки думаю
що думками впораюся